die star links satelliten die ihren mast
in die erdumlaufbahn schickt um die
gesamte erde mit internet zu versorgen
könnten auch für außerirdische
zivilisationen gespannt sein
laut dem astrophysiker sasa ostmann oft
bekommt die erde dadurch ihre erste
techno signatur eine mega struktur also
die irgendwann auf dem radar einer weit
entfernten zivilisation erscheinen wird
kriegs und sein sind future gibt es
dreimal pro woche spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen
tesla und spacex chef elon musk hat mit
seinem projekt star legt wirklich großes
vorher macht ernst mit der
netzversorgung auf der gesamten er hat
60 millionen menschen in abgelegenen und
ländlichen gebieten soll s darling schon
bald mit internet versorgen rund 1300
stahl im internet satelliten umkreisen
die erde derzeit in einer höhe von 550
kilometern und in den kommenden jahren
soll ihre zahlen noch mal rasant in die
höhe steigen fast 12.000 satelliten köln
es bald sein und für bis zu 30.000
weitere satelliten hat space experiment
rege eingereicht doch nicht nur für das
leben auf der erde wird diese
konstellation aus tausenden satelliten
folgen haben
das schreibt jetzt der physiker sasa
osmann auf aus georgien in einem neuen
artikel
demnach könnte das gigantische
satelliten netzwerk von starling die
erde erstmalig für außerirdische
zivilisationen sichtbar machen die
satelliten am nachthimmel könnten so
also irgendwann auch mal auf dem radar
von weit entfernten zivilisationen in
unserer galaxis erscheinen der ausbau
der satelliten könnte sich der zuerst
ein mega struktur der erde entwickeln
dazu später mehr
schon seit dem start des starling
projekts bekommt ihre master für viel
aufmerksamkeit aber auch kritik sein
ziel ist es internet mit
höchstgeschwindigkeit für alle möglich
zu machen und zwar bis zu 1 gigabit pro
sekunde pro nutzer immer wieder betont
mast dass sein plan unter anderem darauf
ab zieht möglicherweise milliarden von
ökonomisch benachteiligten menschen zu
helfen
realisiert werden soll das projekt
darlehen mit hilfe von etwa 12.000
kleinen satelliten die in verschiedener
höhe
die erde kreisen laut plan sollte diese
mega konstellation am satelliten im jahr
2027 am himmel sein vor zwei jahren mai
2009 10 waren die ersten 60 satelliten
auf den weg gebracht worden
doch schnell hagelte es kritik denn
schon bald gab es im netz videos davon
zu sehen wie die satelliten ihre bahn
über den nachthimmel zogen quasi wie an
einer schnur aufgefädelt einer nach dem
anderen zum entsetzen vieler erwarten
sie dabei eben sehr deutlich am dunklen
himmel zu erkennen und der grund dafür
ist die solarpaneele der starting
satelliten reflektieren das licht der
sonne auf die erde
eine hitzige debatte wurde losgetreten
zum größten teil auf twitter wie soll
man sich den himmel vorstellen wenn er
demnächst einmal von hunderten
satelliten beleuchtet wird würde das
vielleicht sogar im schlimmsten fall das
ende der bodengestützten astronomie
bedeuten könnten die stylings satelliten
sternen und galaxien überstrahlen oder
gar verdecken
doch nicht nur das auch andere geschehen
ist am himmel könnten uns diese
befürchtungen zufolge durch die lappen
gehen beispielsweise supernova
explosionen oder aber auch potenziell
gefährliche asteoriden noch schlimmer
ende des vergangenen jahres hatte und
auch der bereich der radioastronomie
alarm geschlagen in einer studie
die extra im kontext des geplanten
radioteleskops kilometer ray sk
durchgeführt wurde befürchteten
fachleute dass das dalí netzwerk
erhebliche auswirkungen haben könnte
das forschungsteam schreibt dazu das
signifikant größere konstellation
bestimmte beobachtungen komplett
unmöglich machen könnten
gemeint ist hier bei einem preis eines
frequenzbandes das zwar auf dem boden
nicht aber im all explizit geschützt ist
in diesen betroffenen frequenzband
finden sich unter anderem die
spektrallinien komplexer probiotischer
moleküle
diese sind entscheidend bei unserer
suche nach außerirdischen leben viele
tausend satelliten würden dann zu
massiven störungen führen so dass man
sehr viel länger beobachten müsste um
das auszugleichen
doch von den fachleuten kamen auch
lösungsvorschläge die satelliten könnten
beispielsweise angewiesen werden die
region um dieses sk nicht anzufangen das
es übrigens eingeplant hatte disco
verbund der eimer zur größten
wissenschaftseinrichtung der welt
anwachsen soll der wissenschaftler sasa
osman aus georgien hat hier seinen
aktuellen artikel auf den treppen server
arxiv veröffentlicht in dem er klarmacht
dass das gigantische netzwerk aus
satelliten aber auch anderweitig
aufmerksamkeit generieren könnte und
zwar bei außerirdischen zivilisationen
demnach könnte das satelliten netz werk
also dazu führen dass die erde erstmals
auch von außerirdischen interesse sein
könnte denn außer frage steht auch wenn
die menschheit im laufe der zeit enorme
technische fortschritte gemacht hat ist
unser planet für potentielles leben da
draußen noch weitestgehend unsichtbar
heißt im klartext wenn es da draußen
eine fortgeschrittene außerirdische
zivilisation gibt die nach weiterem
leben im kosmos sucht dann wird sie
höchstwahrscheinlich im moment noch nur
sehr wenige hinweise auf die menschliche
existenz finden bislang denn genau das
könnte sich mit dem ausbau des starling
netzwerks ändern
der astrophysiker sah so aus man oft
spricht sogar von der ersten zitat mega
struktur der erde und die könnte dann
seiner ansicht nach über kurz oder lang
eben auch auf dem radar von aliens
zivilisationen landen konkret wird die
gigantische größe des netzwerks der erde
sogar ihre erste techno signatur
verleihen
hiermit sind im großen und ganzen
messbare wirkung oder eigenschaften
gemeint die beweise für vergangene oder
gegenwärtige technologien liefern können
die nasa hatte den begriff im rahmen
eines workshops mal so definiert techno
signaturen sind zeichen oder signale die
ist so sie beobachtet werden können uns
erlauben die existenz von dortigen
technologisch entwickelten leben
anzunehmen die uns derzeit bekannteste
techno signatur sind radiosignale wie
sie im rahmen der klassischen wti
astronomie mittels radioteleskopen
gesucht werden aber es gibt noch
zahlreiche andere signaturen die auch
vorhandene technologien hindeuten können
die wir bislang aber noch nicht
ausreichend in betracht gezogen haben
mögliche alternativen sind
beispielsweise optische signale wie sie
von lesern ausgesandt werden könnten
so hat die nase in diesem rahmen also
entschieden techno signaturen genauer
ins visier
zu nehmen für die jahre 2008 und 2009 10
hatte der us-kongress für die suche nach
signaturen technologisch entwickelter
außerirdischer zivilisationen sogar 20
millionen us dollar zur verfügung
gestellt so wenn man also bei der suche
nach außerirdischen leben ganz neue wege
gehen
doch läuft das möglicherweise auch schon
anders rum suchen außerirdische
zivilisationen derzeit auch schon nach
leben im kosmos also nach uns falls sie
es tun sollte die erde über die mega
struktur des starling netzwerks relativ
einfach auch zu spüren sein
der astrophysiker saison ausläuft stellt
in seinem neuen artikel jedenfalls fest
dass instrumente wie beispielsweise das
very large telescope in chile oder aber
auch das chinesische fast radioteleskop
technisch gesehen so weit sind um solche
mega strukturen wie starling im weltraum
lokalisieren zu können
für außerirdische zivilisation mit
vergleichbarer oder sogar noch besserer
technik sollte es seiner meinung nach
also ein leichtes sein
die erde und das leben auf ihr auch zu
spüren für die analyse von sasa ost noch
braucht vor allem eine frage besonders
spannend wann wird der entscheidende
wendepunkt stattfinden wann also wird
das darlehen netzwerk für einen weit
entfernten beobachter erkennbar
fest steht dazu muss es noch sehr viel
weiter wachsen seine analyse ergibt dass
diese mega konstellation bis zu einer
entfernung von 520 licht jahren erfasst
werden könnte wenn das gigantische
netzwerk vollständig hochgefahren ist
aus man schätzt dass da liegt letztlich
für instrumente wie das very large
telescope auf planeten einer entfernung
von bis zu 260 lichtjahren sichtbar sein
könnte während instrumente die mit dem
fast teleskop vergleichbar sind die mega
konstellation wahrscheinlich sogar bis
zu einer entfernung von 500 20
lichtjahren erfassen können
dies würden natürlich erfordern das wie
gesagt dass darling netzwerk vollständig
hochgefahren ist was wahrscheinlich noch
eine beträchtliche zeit in anspruch
nehmen wird wie wir uns diese techno
signatur der erde am ende vorstellen
können ist noch nicht ganz klar denn die
gesamtzahl der internet- satelliten ist
ja noch längst nicht erreicht spacex
selbst hat aber bereits eine
inoffizielle analyse des
erscheinungsbildes stalin netzwerks
veröffentlicht und den man könnte die
techno signatur der erde an radio
denn erinnern die die erde umspannen was
meint ihr ist es wahrscheinlich dass
tatsächlich aliens zivilisation den
kosmos nach leben absuchen oder sind wir
die einzigen schreibt mir gerne meinen
die kommentare auf meinem channel astro
comics tv habe ich übrigens erklärt ob
alien spezies sogar schon die galaxis
durchstreifen um uns vielleicht zu
vernichten kriegt auf das angezeigte
video um mehr über diese sogenannte
dunkle wald theorie zu erfahren
ich freue mich natürlich auch sehr wenn
ihr meinen channel astro comics tv
abonnieren würde und mir so hilft mein
ziel von 60.000 abos zu erreichen auf
einem kanal gibt es zweimal pro woche
aktuelle infos aus dem weltraum
vielleicht sehen wir uns ja mal dort
würde mich freuen
ansonsten leute bleibt neugierig bis
dann bleibt dran